there's different works with different
impacts I mean what I hope is that i
will write a few poems that Lodge in
people's memory and you know that is the
highest aspiration of a poet some of the
pros I've written some of the essays
I've written I know in a sense of
changed at least American and some
European countries sense of what the
role of literature is the role of poetry
is in society but you know pro is I
think an especially critical prose
nonfiction of prose is by its nature
almost always ephemeral you know you you
change the conversation for a moment if
the essay is still read 10-15 years
later and I've been lucky to have essays
that are still red 10 or 15 years later
I mean that's the most you can hope for
you